[Musique]
tu veux que je te raconte une histoire
flippante
il faut que tu gardes le contrôle ou et
alex maintenant
pourquoi tu me dis pas ce qui s'est
passé avec and cheap
c'est vraiment trop bizarre aujourd'hui
sérieux c'est quelque chose qu'elle t'a
dit vas-y offre comme ça tu verras la
tête de con de mon père je dirai rien
[Musique]
je suis là si tapson mois pour quoi que
ce soit je vais compter à rebours à
partir de 10 est à tu travailleras maman
tu devrais pas être là
alex est encore là oui elle doit rester
dormir ici
si les clés de la bagnole de mon père
tu veux bien laisser hadji tranquille tu
arriveras jamais à croire ce qui est en
train de m'arriver qu'elle citait du
amis par l'accusé ce taux à ce problème
[Musique]
ne va pas être là
[Applaudissements]
wahaha
c'est le moment de se réveiller
il était temps qu'on se rencontre